okay yeah I think the point is about
India being a superpower I think it's
wanted a big that happens about an
objective and about what power actually
means let's look at Power first I think
if you were to look at either india and
the dimension of talent within the
convention of power it could be many
things to many people to me i think
fundamentally we are a very tolerant
country so intrinsically we have the
ability to do what we believe we wanted
to do so I think tolerance is the
underlying essence of what we do and and
our focus is being built around that to
me I think power stems from how we
leverage our internal capabilities to to
tell you about what we can actually
deliver as a nation so power could mean
you know how do we utilize our Italian
food in the country how do we go
energize and leverage the the natural
resources that's in the country to
actually be far more productive
self-sufficient and the other dimension
is the one on super I think super is
Anna jacket again is a super later in
terms of what we could do as a nation so
if you were to intrinsically liberate
some of the underlying a sense of what
power to know it's I think it would be a
far better nation than what we eat the
proprietary go ahead so I can't get it
to go ahead it's my favorite topic or
you wanna go ahead the the aspect of the
essence of india also lies with how
other countries and nations actually
look at India from their perspective I
think so what we typically been doing is
an inward outward look in terms of
saying hey this is India this is the
outside environment and it's time for
the others to look at as in terms of
what we are capable of so today when you
hear of you know leveraging India's
capabilities it's about saying hey what
the US is think about India and what
some of the other nations are thinking
about in here I think it's time for
India to say hey this is what we stand
for and start leveraging some of those
to me let's look at some of the
dimensions of what the basic elements of
nature's are let's look at water in fact
there's a theory going now to say that
you know the fight for the the world in
the next say 15-20 years is going to be
on water
let's look at energy another derivative
of what what power is all about so if
when we look at some of these demands
that in India has got extreme
capabilities in terms of what we could
do in these space to be able to achieve
what we would typically call a super bot
so I think it's in assets it's each one
of us in terms of our ability to believe
in oneself and say hey I think we are
you know a nation which which is very
proud of what we do and what we capable
of doing so I think self-belief and
believing in all the eject is that comma
away and then raising our internal
capabilities probably the best way to
look at what we could do as a nation
yeah so the other